okay so I told myself d23 is going on
right now I'm hanging out at home if
there's a trailer for the mandalorian
I'll talk about that I mean obviously
episode 9 as well but definitely
mandalorian does Mandalorians like the
thing on Disney Plus I'm looking forward
to most
I mean Clone Wars is cool too they get
in the final season but for me it's
really Mandalorians the coolest sounding
thing it's actually a thing that would
tempt me to get Disney Plus I just want
to sit it out like the Solarians and the
crew of the Normandy I really want to
hold the line Frasor more epic later
than that I'm really trying to resist
Disney Plus I mean it's gonna have some
cool stuff on there but I just I want to
be like no [ __ ] you I don't need you
however we have a trailer to the
mandalorian and it looks pretty sweet I
mean pretty dark too like Vlad the
Impaler style heads on spikes bodies
getting cut in half by doors this is
like a different kind of Star Wars thing
though I will say Attack of the Clones
the body count in there is pretty
businesslike Geno seems they're
intelligent sentient life forms and
they're getting sliced in half crushed
to death no one gave it [ __ ] however
back to the Mandalorian which is really
it's a compelling idea because are we
gonna address the fact that this dude's
Boba Fett like he's Boba Fett right what
we're supposed to believe he's not Boba
Fett I know Boba Fett's not technically
a Mandalorian but no one in this world
would know that they'd probably just
call him the Mandalorians also you never
hear him talk because we would recognize
the voice but like that's to Mara
Morrison's voice oh that's Boba Fett
right if he could just be some other
clone that's probably why we haven't
heard him talk at all I just I haven't
heard him talk the biggest thing that
made me go okay so he is Boba Fett is
the Carbonite the frozen Carbonite
bodies it's a natural string to connect
is a natural connection to make right
it's like gonna galaxy far far away
there's this guy who looks like a
Mandalorian and in the trailer for him
there are bodies frozen in carbonite who
else in that galaxy has used Carbonite
oh that's right that other guy who looks
like a Mandalorian it's kind of like if
they had a horror movie that took place
in the Texas Chainsaw Massacre universe
and then there's one shot you had people
on meat hooks hanging their meat hooks
not being made for human bodies but
there was the character Leatherface who
used it for such a purpose it would be a
natural leap to be like so that's
totally Leatherface doing that right I
suppose I just could be what bounty
hunters do like oh yeah you use it for
not human beings but trust us it's a
really efficient way to get someone from
point 8
won't be with no house like things can
have multiple uses handcuffs for
prisoners also handcuffs for not
prisoners whoever the Mandalorian is he
straight up stole serenity from Malcolm
Reynolds's [ __ ] it looks like that does
I don't know it's what I thought I don't
know you thought of but surrendered but
who knows maybe that's a call back
because serenity was inspired by the
Millennium Falcon and now it's full
circle but this show looks like it has
really good effects like it has a solid
budget to send them a style budget for a
streaming show that's really impressive
I expected this to be more boots on the
ground and I mean it might be for 99.9%
of the actual show and they're just
showing you a couple of Star Wars ash
things even for what they showed this
impressive stuff let's watch that one
scene one more time there's just so it
feels it doesn't feel Star Wars ish I
don't know that that's even a bad thing
I mean it looks cool doesn't feel like
the fundamental hero's journey and
redemption and all that stuff it's like
nah we're just Mandalorian peace
probably an [ __ ] but he's gonna be
business and he might actually kick a
lot of ass also ig-88
I heard some people like that's not a
g88 it's another Eiji I'm gonna call him
ig-88
biggest thing I'm hoping for come on man
come on you know you wanted to you know
you want it to Kevin Costner's a little
too old now would have been him back in
the day see on the end the Mandalorian
trailer it's a teaser trailer was it
like two minutes long max like a minute
and a half to two minutes long not that
long of a trailer shows you what you
need to know has some grit has some
brutality has some bad assery and a
character who's I guess not Boba Fett to
be clear I'm not banking on the fact
that he is Bubba Fett I don't care like
the Mandalorian can be just this other
cool dude in the end we might walk away
go in he's way cooler than Boba Fett I'm
just saying I haven't heard him talk and
Carbonite bodies that's enough for me to
speculate the Mandalorian trailer have
you seen it what do you think about it
and are you gonna get the Disney
streaming service Disney Plus
realistically I'll probably get it from
Mandalorian then when I watch it Dental
cancel they get me for like two months
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]